yet another Donald Trump staffer has
been heckled at a Mexican restaurant
this is happening daily now yesterday I
told you about Department of Homeland
Security Secretary Kristen Nielsen who
was shouted out of a Mexican restaurant
by protesters here is video of that she
was confronted about her role in the
separation from parents and internment
of children in camps and cages and she
did not get a warm welcome at a Mexican
restaurant Lee the Trump administration
staffers must really like Mexican food
because Stephen Miller Trump's
completely depraved and demented policy
advisor was heckled at another Mexican
restaurant in Washington DC a couple of
days ago with shouts of fascist one
customer reportedly yelling out hey look
guys whoever thought we'd be in a
restaurant with a real-life fascist
begging for money for new cages and as
the heckling escalated Stephen Miller
reportedly said nothing but scurried
away from protesters as reported by New
York Magazine did not leave the
restaurant however like Kristen Nielsen
and these incidents are hilariously
similar for me the big difference is I
imagine Stephen Miller being there as a
sort of fu well I see Kristen Nielsen
being in a Mexican restaurant because
she has no idea about the irony of it
and I got got a bunch of emails saying
don't Stephen Miller and Nielsen realize
that they're obviously getting
spit in their food and I actually am not
sure about that and the reason has
nothing to do with the views or their
actions that we've seen from Miller and
from Nielsen I just think that the
mostly Latin American immigrants who are
doing the cooking at these in many
restaurants they take the job of food
preparation seriously they're
professionals and as disgusting as I'm
sure they find the actions of Stephen
Miller and Kristen Nielsen I think that
on principle they would do their job and
prepare the food correctly and
respectfully I could be wrong maybe they
did end up eating somebody else's bodily
fluids in their food this week but I
actually am not immediately assuming
that they got spit in their food
yeah and I'm all for the free expression
of speech right these people being
berated in public and humiliated that's
all well and good right I don't want
anyone to spit in their food I don't
want anyone to attack them physically
that would be fake spews and that is not
something that we would stand for when
will the Trump administration release a
statement equating Steve Steven Miller
with Rosa Parks for having had the
courage to face adversity enter the
Lions Den and have some ceviche but Who
am I kidding
this Miller looked like the type of guy
who would go and have the ceviche at a
Mexican restaurant he seems more like
the type who had ordered the blandest
possible thing because spices might be
scary or just ask for the chicken
fingers off the kids menu because he
just can't handle anything with some
spice in all seriousness they love being
the victims and that is how they are
going to spin this send me your thoughts
on Stephen Miller heckled at a Mexican
restaurant